bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est avec
maeva et on va parler de la logbox en
vitamines
[Musique]
n'at il pas ce que tu peux nous
présenter cette fameuse bourse alors la
logbox la lobaye c'est une boîte l'amour
connectés qui sert à envoyer des
messages d'amour
les gens qu'on aime 1
ça marche avec une application grille
sur laquelle on envoie les messages
photos et à solers cette application on
envoie le message la personne qui est la
leur box qui reçoit le message la masse
m à tomber et pour pouvoir justement
faire en sorte que le coeur s'arrête il
faut le couvercle découvert le message
qui est à l'arrêt depuis le message qui
à l'intérieur
exactement c'est un portrait voir si on
va bien alors miroir j'espère que ça se
verra la camair
non j'ai un peu compliqué voilà je sais
un message un petit peu caché et nos
gars i wish you a lovely day love you
mon accent est à peu près aussi matière
c'est ça d'accord donc ça veut dire que
les personnes qui vont envoyer le
message à son smartphone c'est un en bas
le petit message d'amour sur la neufbox
la personne qu'est la neufbox reçoit son
pétrole après étude doit répondre à
partir de ton smartphone ou si c'est ça
alors c'est ça exactement alors partie
qu'on peut savoir c'est que la leur box
ne peux pas répondre au message qui a
été envoyé par contre pour répondre et
l'envoyé de l'amour avec leurs doigts
fait tomber le prix car hélas la
personne à recevoir une pluie de coeur
sur son téléphone
[Musique]
je sais pas
on a renvoyé de l'amour aux personnes
qui nous ont envoyé à travers le message
donc ça veut dire que alors que le
couvert qui n'est pas connecté ou s'ils
s'y reconnaît le message il ya un petit
capteur qui vécurent un petit capteur
qui est là là donc du coup qu'on soulève
le couvercle ca affiche le message fait
la pige pas sinon sinon voila ca
n'affiche pas de message or donc la
j'enlève ça et on a un style vous par
exemple
dix ans quand des passants maliens les
ans de vie napoléon un hibou hockey et
donc si je vous renvoyer un petit
message d'amour je la prends déjà fait
tourner et armand file en changeant une
piqueur c'est génial
et alors il ya ce cas un sens qu'à
différents messages elle aurait
justement ça pourrait être intéressant
effectivement qui importe que ce soit la
gauche ou la droite un virage automne là
je t'aime pas par exemple
sinon je te fais la gueule non non non
elle n'a pas souhaité jeudi amour de
l'amour tu as raison alors du coup il ya
un petit cap qui connecte et ça ça
correspond à quoi voilà alors en fait
c'est branché sur secteur ça marche avec
le wifi également nous couler leur
matrice fonctionner il faut l'approcher
sur métier auquel vont également qu'il
sera branché constamment sur secteur
voilà sa demande pas beaucoup de
batteries surtout sommes pas grand chose
mais c'est son petit fonctionnement elle
est super jolie et alors c'est quoi
l'enjeu
le bois alors c'est du bois de hêtre
quand c'est le cas là c'est 100%
français s'est fabriqué dans notre
langue française et c'est du made in
france ré so sweet way et en a trois
quatre ou pas d'accord j'ai aussi on
atteint jeudi à tulle et usa palestine
et votre coeur je les ai pas
malheureusement de ballons mais voilà on
fait aller les trouver sur nos réseaux
sociaux on les trouve assez facilement
et c'est super bien packagées c'est vrai
c'est joli petit coeur alors du coup
est-ce qu'on peut la trouver cette
neufbox
alors la loque peuvent se pourrait la
retrouver bas ici au bhv bon marché et
dans plusieurs concepts stores également
france et en europe et s'en allait
soumettre internet on vous donnera la
liste des magasins où la trouver pour
l'instant on est en rupture de stock
pendrel non vous les trouvez vous la
trouverez uniquement
dans les magasins dans les magasins si
on en veut tant pis pour les aubert et
ce vers quoi le bon marché exacte est
pas génial mais coûte super alors là
donc pour ça ça vaut combien pour
envoyer de l'amour y avons passé à vos
99 euros
voilà nous fait un bel objet si l'école
est requis et le choisissez théâtre
c'est un objet qui va durer dans le
temps
alors une petite boîte à secret pour
envoyer vos modules à une personne que
vous aimez
voilà exactement c'est super joli c'est
simplement pour de l'amour et de la
positivité et je pense qu'on en a besoin
dans notre monde actuel
bon c'est quelque chose qui met du bien
et qui soude les gens et qui renforce
les liens et c'est quoi l'idée de
l'autre donc ça la base
alors la petite histoire message doit
passer
alors voilà le rugged jamais ce qui est
sympa c'est l'anecdote de comment ça a
été créée bajan est parti aux états unis
pour étudier et sa fiancée mélodie est
resté en place
et voilà il est ingénieur en robotique
et les cons
il a décidé de lui créer cette petite
boîte amour connectés et les marées
poule donc la première un peu de ça les
liens de la kermesse à grenoble aux fab
labs là où on a plein de machines et
comme marie paule est tombé sur cette
neufbox à la ligne c'était incroyable
il faut absolument qu'on en fasse
quelque chose et il faut la partager
au monde les gens le droit aussi de
recevoir de l'amour de cette façon mais
voilà sa part d'une histoire d'amour
très joli saut trop beau produit
positive de l'amour tout ça donne une
superbe
merci beaucoup dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez est ce que ça vous dirait
d'envoyer de l'amour à travers la
neufbox vous ne marquez tout ça en
commentaire on en parle ensemble je vous
invite à me laisser des gens y pousse à
vous abonner à la chaîne parce qu'on a
toujours parlé d'amour on va parler de
jolis produite
vous avez le lien de la neufbox dans la
description mais je vous dis à très
bientôt
ciao
[Musique]